Alec Baldwin you know what I'm saying
the [__] Legend okay
[Music]
Alex
yeah come on lady died bro oh I was
talking about how he had just had his
seventh kid Oh
blank in his life
and movies
he's like Akash with a [__] gun bro
he can't miss my boy
okay so what's the deal so he's been
indicted is that what it's called yeah
he's basically one of three people being
charged with involuntary manslaughter
what is the difference Alex between
being indicted and charged that's the
same
same thing yeah okay so he's charged
with involuntary manslaughter for the
shooting of his Director of Photography
that's correct yes you're right oh [__]
you're nice boy hey thanks don't tell
yourself short in your memory man hey
thanks
random things one or two words always
now so break that so break the whole
thing down he is being charged by the
D.A and they basically need to charge
you they need to have like grounds to
charge you yeah and what they're saying
is you are being charged for pulling the
trigger which I don't think you're
supposed to do on a set unless like
everybody's clear or whatever but she's
he's saying there's no reason to charge
me and she's saying no the reason we
took so long to charge you is because I
wanted to hear back from the FBI on
whether or not this trigger was playing
[__] and I knew that
[__] was guilty I remember I was
doing that joke for a minute yeah do you
guys remember that on tour I was doing
the there was doing this little like
Alec Baldwin joke but I was basically
saying that I knew for a fact that he
did it once he said he didn't pull the
trigger you know I don't mind giving you
credit but I don't think you're the only
person who does yourself I love you and
I give you credit a lot
[Laughter]
[Music]
I apologize but I said he did it on
purpose I I don't I don't really think
he wanted to kill her but I do think
that he wanted to like shock her
because if you're not even filming and
you're just and you're pulling a trigger
with a blank right you're annoyed by the
person you're working out the angle for
a shot I don't think they're actually
recording so they're working out and
then you know that they're blanks in a
gun you're assuming so it's gonna make a
pop right or just all that pop sound
that kind of stuff to go on post
I don't know I don't know necessarily I
don't know I would assume a blank's
still possible the blank's still pops
because the blank I believe has the
powder it just doesn't have the
projectile yeah so
maybe you're [__] annoyed this DP has
given you a bunch of notes you want to
deal with it or the director's right
behind they keep on saying all this
[__] up [__] and then you're like all
right I'm gonna scare them I'm gonna
take out I'm like passive aggressively
bother these [__] and then you
ended up shooting them yeah but the fact
that he was like no I didn't even pull
the trigger it's like you you go and you
say you [__] pull the trick
everything you say you feel bad about
it you know he has a fist fight with a
guy over a parking spot nah that was in
New York City right he'd been having his
there's like a crazy voicemail his
daughter I almost shot somebody over
pocket yeah Alec Baldwin like to be that
much of a lunatic knowing that if you
get in a fight in the streets
everybody's gonna videotape it because
you're a person has been famous for 50
years like you have to be a real lunatic
you have to be someone who can't control
their emotions at all in public if
you're if you're a regular dude that got
a job another person is taking your
parking spot I fight it out you're not
gonna lose your job over there I respect
it it's like ah knowing who I am knowing
this is going to make the news
that's how you know he's out of it no
what if the guy violated me so now I'm
oh I gotta just be there
20 million dollar home yeah you'll get
violated sometimes if you're worth that
much money and you let it slide and if
you got to that and I'm not even saying
like an income joke but you get to that
level of income I promise you you're
gonna be like okay violate me I'm rich
put it this way it's like I'm not losing
Rich because I don't like it violent
remember when they fought the people in
the in the crowd at the uh the Pacers
game yeah malice in the palace yeah
miles to the Palace like all of us are
like yeah you can't just talk to anybody
the way you won't slap the [__] out of
somebody but you're still a lunatic for
going into the crowd and punching
somebody because you have so much money
to lose so much opportunity to lose
it's just not the smartest it's not the
most emotionally intelligent thing to do
even though as a man you go well [__] if
you're gonna do that but you're also
probably thinking if I know you in that
situation your Primal urge is like I'm
gonna [__] this guy up but your money
urge is going he got one yeah how much
do I got to lose yeah you're gonna pay
for a garage yeah that's what you're
gonna do also yeah you know what I mean
like and it's definitely different with
male female Dynamics but there's a
reason Jay-Z and just Solange Jay-Z did
absolutely nothing if Alice Muslim was
in Jay-Z's situation he might kill them
both
I need to pull the trigger both of their
[__] heads I need a pull the trigger
he also has and if we can get it
emotionally but he got into it with a
stewardess because he refused to get off
his phone as the plan was taken off oh
yeah and he was just like I'm not
getting off my phone he also left a
crazy voicemail email for his daughter
and she was like 12 at the time he
called her a greedy little pig or
something like that like the guy at the
very least will fly off the handle
Looney at the very least he'll fly off
the [__] zero emotional intelligence
and just anger takes over and he can't
do anything which are usually like my
favorite people to hang around to be
honest with you just being around
something like like I mean dub has a lot
of emotional intelligence but he is so
easily like he's always in a state of
like emotional distress yeah and I just
love it it's like the most entertaining
that's why he's magic for a vlog because
there's never a moment where he's
feeling calm it's always a moment of
emotional distress so you put the camera
on him and it's magic all right so what
do you guys think what's going on does
he end up going to prison I think he's
[__] because they're charging him as
the shooter and the producer explain
that so as a shooter you could say look
I pulled a trigger but nobody said it
was a hot Gun there's not supposed to be
a [__] bullet in there I just pull
the trigger because I I'm an actor and
I'm trying to be in character or
whatever your reasoning is yeah but then
they're gonna say okay well if you're
gonna blame this armorer who handed the
gun over you're the producer
you're still liable now I'm sure that's
a smaller punishment or whatever but I
feel like he gets charged no matter what
on any in any way there's no way you're
not getting charged it feels like he
would lose the civil case for something
like this as a producer yeah and then
there would be like the insurance that
the movie has that would like I guess
take on the responsibility of that
criminal case no the Civil one he would
lose but the criminal I can't see him
going out of prison for it like
sorry I can't see him going to prison
for
the producer role for pulling the
trigger maybe if he's not supposed to
pull a trigger in that situation on set
but for being the producer and then the
armor was uh negligent yeah criminal
negligence yeah like I I think it's
really hard because if you're the
producer of a movie now you're taking on
the criminal liability of 400 people
that work on a movie like nobody would
ever even produce a movie but civilly I
can see it happening I see him getting
the producer charge and not the
involuntary mantle but I think he's
saying the producer charge won't carry
jail time yeah
yeah we're on the same page but do you
think he will get found guilty of that
in a civil court no no in criminal of
the producer one I think you will does
that have a punishment of jail time I
think it depends on the punishment if it
doesn't you think he will get charged
guilty yeah okay I think the lesser the
charge same place yeah yeah if it's like
he's responsible for that life that's
lost and he's gonna have to do 20 years
or whatever that is or 10 years like
whatever you get the max is five years
and I think that's for shooting and I
think for producer it's 18 months and I
could be wrong in that because I'm not
still they're also leveraging I think
they're leveraging two charges against
him and one is more severe than the
other one that's according to the CNN
article that I read they're like one is
basically saying like so it's fake news
yeah exactly it's fake news completely
not real but if basically it's like
criminal negligence or it is like a form
of negligence that isn't necessarily
criminal or something like that but
basically there's two charges and the
jury gets to pick which charge they want
to go forward with and then depending on
which one they go forward with then
that'll dictate what the sentencing is
if he's found guilty I I think he's
found guilty and he avoids jail time got
you that's my guess I'm wondering if
they're trying to like get him to
testify against the armor
oh oh [__] we're like they're like we
want to get this person the armor is
ultimately and most people I think
recognize like oh the armor is like the
person that's like most responsible here
yeah I think the first D.A that grabbed
the gun that handed it to him in the
first place pleaded guilty already to
like negligence and so that's the third
person that was charged out of all of
them I think he should be charged as a
producer how you hire this shitty ass
armorer yeah I had a better armor in Las
Vegas than you had on this [__] he's not
higher in the armor this is a producer
name only I imagine like where you
basically give a producer credit how
happy do you think Hollywood execs are
where they're like all these [__]
actors do a movie they gotta be producer
yeah well now you got what you wanted
[__] yeah yeah you're gonna put
in name only right next to that [__]
like I don't think he actually hired her
like made the call but he had a much
bigger role because like this was him
like this was an independent movie that
he was putting up a lot of the money so
it's like he does have a lot more say
over what happens isn't the girl's dad
also like the armorer's dad was awesome
professional like Hollywood yeah so
she's like a nepo baby yeah yeah and she
had like almost zero experience yeah so
yeah it isn't but I think that's one of
those things where it's like especially
when it comes to Hollywood stuff where
it's easier to get into the Union if you
have a connection and then once you're
in the union you're making I don't know
what they're making a day but probably
like really good money per day so if you
don't have something that you're really
passionate about you might as well get
this like really cushy awesome union job
where you can guarantee work working
with all these famous people and you got
your [__] pops yeah if you're like a
p yeah it's 20 20 but this is such a
high-stakes job to give to a [__] oh
it's an easy
like animal Wrangler nipple baby
think about like to them to them is
nothing like how often does this happen
on a movie I remember uh the crow dude
yeah Brandon Lee or Brandon Lee Brandon
Lee's son sprucey's son like that
happened then and then [__] hasn't
happened since so I think in their mind
they're like there'd never be a live
round yeah it would all be blanks it's
no different than props I imagine for
them right yeah so you're like oh [__]
I'm gonna get all this money my Pop's
gonna hook it up we're gonna do all
these things everything's gonna be good
just like you see Legacy people in
transpo like your pops was a
transportation coordinator you're
getting this 500 day job it's like it's
golden do you think sorry I just had you
think this is why he had to lie on that
interview and say I never even pulled it
down not only to avoid the jail time of
I'm involuntary manslaughter I'm oh
you're saying as a producer yeah oh well
yeah just clearly the gun misfire that
can't be on the producer his lawyers
might have been like yo you could get
pinched for both so we got to figure out
a story that helps to avoid both charges
yeah the truth might help you avoid one
okay